have a wonderful day today thanks honey
I'm so terrible i play a guy who's in
witness protection i'm deeply in love
with kristen bell and I've decided to
leave witness protection to take her to
this job interview in LA give me the
nose with a golf club I didn't think it
would hurt that bad Alex what do you
want I want my money that's it for when
Hayley on him I play the federal marshal
it's a charge of guarding my friend and
when he decides to leave I feel he's at
risk so I follow him enjoyed the movies
really about to me it's about a guy in a
woman when a guy needs a woman and he
falls in love with her he she knows
something about it she may not know
everything about him but we don't want
to tell her everything right way cuz
there's some support kind of ashamed of
we hope that she will tell us something
horrible about her but we don't it
doesn't mean we aren't audit best
friends and you've betrayed me it really
is a great case study about men and
women and how much you reveal once a
woman loves you and you love them you
don't want to mess it up this whole
thing happened really fast and I'm sorry
except for completely lying about who
you are you may have had three ways with
dudes I don't know whoa whoa whoa yeah
it really explores them lying versus
omission right and what is line and what
is just omission when I got into witness
protection I knew it wasn't gonna be
that guy you're a bank robber I didn't
get away driving part well I would love
to tell you about my role as a director
writer and actor in this movie but I
know the second I start talking about it
seriously tom will make fun of me this
one who wouldn't react like just so you
know I never felt you know where the
director you want to go the guys in
charge and he's happy to be there even
if you aren't like he does every night I
never I always thought he knew what was
going on so how's it always happy I'm
not only tapping yeah
you don't like Gudas ago no how's that
why I said more specifically so when did
you stop liking back what year ones